Words that taste like orange candy. Music that projects brilliant, shimmering colors. Numbers that come with personalities and full life stories. These are all forms of synesthesia, a neurological condition in which senses such as taste, touch, smell, and vision, link or merge. Historical accounts of people with synesthesia date back hundreds of years, but it's only in recent decades that scientists have been able to use brain imaging and other modern research methods to gain a better understanding of how synesthesia works and why it might occur. So what does it like to have synesthesia? What might cause it, and how do the brains of people with synesthesia differ from those of people without it? What can we learn about the human mind more
尝起来像橙子糖的味道。投射出绚丽、闪烁色彩的音乐。带有性格和完整人生故事的数字。这些都是联觉的形式，这是一种神经系统疾病，在这种疾病中，味觉、触觉、嗅觉和视觉等感官会相互联系或融合。关于联觉者的历史记载可以追溯到几百年前，但直到最近几十年，科学家们才能够利用脑成像和其他现代研究方法，更好地了解联觉是如何运作的以及它为什么会发生。那么，患有联觉是什么感觉呢？是什么导致了它，联觉者的大脑与非联觉者的大脑有何不同？我们能从研究联觉和其他感官差异中学到什么关于人类思维的知识？
generally from studying synesthesia and other sensory differences? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. Our guest today is Dr. Jules Simner, a professor of neuropsychology at the University of Sussex in the United Kingdom, who specializes in multisensory research. She has studied synesthesia in adults and children for nearly two decades. She also researches other sensory differences, including misophonia, an extreme aversion to certain sounds, and aphantasia, the inability to see pictures in your mind's eye.
通常从研究联觉和其他感官差异中能学到什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我们今天的嘉宾是英国萨塞克斯大学神经心理学教授朱尔斯·辛纳（Dr. Jules Simner）博士，她专门从事多感官研究。她研究成人和儿童的联觉已有近二十年了。她还研究其他感官差异，包括恐音症（对某些声音的极端厌恶）和心盲症（无法在脑海中看到图像）。
discuss these today too and talk about what links these threads of research together. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Simner. Thanks very much for the invitation. Some of our listeners have probably heard of synesthesia, or at least the most common forms of it, like people seeing colors when they hear music. But synesthesia is a lot more varied than people may realize. And you've written and tested for 128 different types. What types are out there? What are the differences in the commonalities? So it's quite hard to estimate exactly how many types of synesthesia there are, because some
今天也会讨论这些问题，并谈谈是什么将这些研究线索联系在一起的。感谢您今天加入我们，辛纳博士。非常感谢您的邀请。我们的一些听众可能听说过联觉，或者至少听说过它最常见的形式，比如人们在听到音乐时会看到颜色。但联觉比人们意识到的要多样化得多。您已经撰写并测试了128种不同的类型。都有哪些类型？它们之间的共同点和区别是什么？所以很难准确估计到底有多少种联觉，因为有些
could be quite well hidden, but the ones we know most about are the ones that people can realize most readily and report to us most easily. And I think for that reason, we tend to think of the most common types of synesthesia as being the ones that trigger unusual colour perceptions. So experiencing colours when you are reading words, looking at numbers, listening to music, and then perhaps more obscurely swimming, so different swimming strokes, causing different colour perceptions, perhaps even reading Braille also
可能隐藏得很好，但我们最了解的是那些人们最容易意识到并最容易向我们报告的类型。我认为正是因为这个原因，我们倾向于认为最常见的联觉类型是那些会触发异常色彩感知的类型。比如在阅读文字、看数字、听音乐时体验到颜色，然后可能更晦涩一点的是游泳，不同的游泳姿势会导致不同的色彩感知，甚至阅读盲文也是如此，
and watching signers in sign language, all of these are known to trigger colours. But as I said, although people talk about colours most often in the context of synesthesia, I think it may be that colours are just the easiest to report because there are many different other synesthetic sensations so you could experience flavours that flood the mouth. So your reading and your mouth is being bombarded with sensations of Yorkshire pudding
还有观看手语翻译者的手语，所有这些已知都会触发颜色。但正如我所说，虽然人们在谈论联觉时最常提到颜色，但我认为这可能只是因为颜色最容易报告，因为还有许多其他不同的联觉感官，比如你可以体验到充满口腔的味道。所以你在阅读时，你的口腔被约克郡布丁的味道所轰炸，
or processed peas or bitter lemon or nice orange fruit sweets which is what Julia tastes of, my name Julia, or perhaps less pleasant taste. so the taste of earwax or other things that you wouldn't want in your mouth, maybe vomit and so on. So that's also another type of synesthesia we know about. But to answer your question, there are many different kinds of synesthesia. They can trigger colours, taste, smells, textures, bodily feelings, and the compulsion even to put your body into certain shapes or formation.
或者是加工过的豌豆、苦柠檬，或者是好吃的橙子味水果糖——这就是朱莉娅（Julia）尝起来的味道，我的名字叫朱莉娅——或者可能是不太愉快的味道。比如耳垢的味道或其他你不想在嘴里的东西，也许是呕吐物等等。所以这也是我们所知的另一种联觉。但回答你的问题，联觉有很多种。它们可以触发颜色、味觉、嗅觉、质地、身体感觉，甚至强迫你把身体摆成某种形状或姿势。
So I remember a very rare case from many years ago. of a professor who had an urge to form shapes with his body in response to different words that he heard. So many types. So you said your name has a flavor? Is that universal? How does your name have a flavor? Yeah, that's a good point. So what I described to you, and I think he wouldn't mind me mentioning this at all,
我记得多年前有一个非常罕见的案例，一位教授在听到不同的词语时，有一种用身体摆出形状的冲动。所以类型非常多。那么你说你的名字有一种味道？这是普遍的吗？你的名字是怎么有味道的？是的，这是一个很好的观点。所以我向你描述的，我想他完全不介意我提到这一点，
what I described to you was the taste of the, the taste of the name Julia, as experienced by synestique James Wannerton. James Wannerton is a particularly special and important synestate for me. Not only have I studied James for the last 20 years, but James has been an amazing advocate for the synesthesia community. He is the president of the UK Synesthesia Association, and he has taken part in so much outreach himself to help people to understand the condition.
我向你描述的是联觉者詹姆斯·万纳顿（James Wannerton）所体验到的“朱莉娅”这个名字的味道。詹姆斯·万纳顿对我来说是一位特别重要且特殊的联觉者。过去20年里，我不仅研究了詹姆斯，而且詹姆斯一直是联觉社区的一位了不起的倡导者。他是英国联觉协会的主席，他自己也参与了大量的推广工作，帮助人们了解这种疾病。
And for James, the name Julia tastes of orange fruit sweets. It's actually a branded fruit sweet. Yeah, and the interesting thing is most people call me Jules Simner. They use my nickname Jules, but with James, we don't do that because Jules does not taste as nice as Julia. Jules has a bit of an unpleasant taste. James politely tells me it tastes of porridge. I think it may actually taste of drool or saline. because we know that there are links between the word that trigger synesthesia and the type of taste experienced.
对詹姆斯来说，“朱莉娅”这个名字尝起来像橙子味的水果糖。它实际上是一种品牌水果糖。是的，有趣的是，大多数人叫我朱尔斯·辛纳（Jules Simner）。他们用我的昵称朱尔斯，但对于詹姆斯，我们不这样做，因为“朱尔斯”尝起来没有“朱莉娅”那么好。朱尔斯有一种不太愉快的味道。詹姆斯礼貌地告诉我它尝起来像粥。我想它实际上可能尝起来像口水或盐水。因为我们知道触发联觉的词语与所体验到的味觉类型之间存在联系。
And from my 20 years of research, I rather suspect that Jules tastes of drool, which is why we use the name Julia. So do people with music and color synesthesia actually see colors in the world around them when they hear music? or is it more like just something in their mind's eye? So the answer to that depends on the synestite you're speaking to because there are several different ways that synesthetes can experience their colour. So this was captured quite nicely by our colleagues, Mike Dixon and Daniel Smilick and their team in Canada. They were able to name projector synesthetes versus associator synesthetes.
根据我20年的研究，我相当怀疑朱尔斯尝起来像口水，这就是为什么我们使用“朱莉娅”这个名字。那么，患有音乐和颜色联觉的人在听到音乐时，真的能在周围的世界中看到颜色吗？还是更像是在他们脑海中的某种东西？所以答案取决于你正在交谈的联觉者，因为联觉者体验颜色的方式有几种不同。这被我们在加拿大的同事迈克·迪克森（Mike Dixon）和丹尼尔·斯米利克（Daniel Smilick）及其团队很好地捕捉到了。他们能够命名为“投射型联觉者”和“联想型联觉者”。
So associate a synesthetes experience their colours somewhere in the mind's eye like a kind of strong internal mental imagery. Projector synesthetes will see their colours projected out in the outside world. So a couple of examples. If you have coloured letters and numbers and are a projector synesthet, you may see those colours superimposed onto the text that you're reading. or if I'm sure he wouldn't mind me describing or as described to me by synesthesia scientist Julian Asher, those colours can be projected out there in the world floating in space. So Julian Asher is a geneticist who helped us to understand the genetics of synesthesia. And he told me that when he was a young boy, his parents would take him to the symphony.
所以联想型联觉者在脑海中体验他们的颜色，就像一种强烈的内在心理意象。投射型联觉者会看到他们的颜色投射到外面的世界中。举几个例子。如果你有彩色的字母和数字，并且是一名投射型联觉者，你可能会看到这些颜色叠加在你正在阅读的文本上。或者，如果我不介意描述的话，或者正如联觉科学家朱利安·阿舍（Julian Asher）向我描述的那样，这些颜色可以投射到外面的世界中，漂浮在太空中。朱利安·阿舍是一位帮助我们了解联觉遗传学的遗传学家。他告诉我，当他还是个小男孩时，他的父母会带他去听交响乐。
And he assumed that the house lights dimmed so that people could see the colours better. Because for him, the orchestra has colours floating above it. He actually thought, why else would anybody dim the house lights apart from to see the synesthetic colours better? That's amazing. So in your mind or in the outside world, yeah. And sometimes experiencing in unusual ways, I remember a student of mine from 20 years ago who experienced pain as colors, and for her, the colors were a cone that projected from her head
他以为把大厅的灯光调暗是为了让人们能更好地看到颜色。因为对他来说，管弦乐队上方漂浮着颜色。他实际上想，除了为了更好地看到联觉颜色之外，还有谁会把大厅的灯光调暗呢？这太神奇了。所以是在你的脑海里还是在外部世界，是的。有时以不寻常的方式体验，我记得20年前我的一名学生，她将疼痛体验为颜色，对她来说，颜色是一个从她头上投射出来的圆锥体，
in color. And if she thought very hard about the shape of the cone, she could moderate the pain of the headache. How common is synesthesia and what's the prevalence in the population? Do we know? Well, yes, so this is something I've spent quite a lot of the last 20 years looking into. our first estimates for commonness were based on asking synesthetes to come forward. So there was a very nice study by Simon Baron Cohen and his colleagues in 1996, and they placed an advert in the newspaper in Cambridge, UK, and it described synesthesia, and it asked synesthetes to come forward. And he found that the prevalence of synesthesia was one in 2000 from that study.
带有颜色。如果她非常努力地思考圆锥体的形状，她就能减轻头痛的痛苦。联觉有多普遍，它在人口中的患病率是多少？我们知道吗？嗯，是的，这是我过去20年里花了很多时间研究的问题。我们最初对普遍性的估计是基于要求联觉者主动站出来。所以1996年西蒙·巴伦-科恩（Simon Baron Cohen）和他的同事进行了一项非常好的研究，他们在英国剑桥的报纸上刊登了一则广告，描述了联觉，并要求联觉者站出来。在那项研究中，他发现联觉的患病率是两千分之一。
Now, of course, unfortunately, and of course they knew this, they would be radically underestimating because they were relying on synesthetes to buy the newspaper that day, to read the article, to come forward, you know, which are lots of things that filter out people through that process. So in 2000 and in the early 2000s, my colleague Jamie Ward and I decided to, instead of relying on synest seats to come forward, we started to go out into the general population. We would gather large groups of people together and screen every single one of them. And this gave us a sort of better estimate, really, of the prevalence of synesthesia. And since then, I've individually screened almost 20,000 people
当然，不幸的是，他们当然知道这一点，他们会严重低估，因为他们依赖于联觉者那天买报纸、阅读文章、站出来，你知道，这中间有很多过滤掉人们的过程。所以在2000年和21世纪初，我的同事杰米·沃德（Jamie Ward）和我决定，不再依赖联觉者主动站出来，我们开始走进普通人群。我们会召集大群人，并对他们每个人进行筛查。这确实给了我们一个关于联觉患病率的更好的估计。从那时起，我已经单独筛查了近2万人
for synesthesia. And from that, we have quite a good idea that synesthesia is at least 4.4% in the population. So at least one in 23 people have synesthesia. In that study, we were looking at around 140 different types of synesthesia, but we had missed out some quite crucial types. So we also know independently that around 10% of people see time or numbers or letters mapped out in space. Now, that would add another sort of 10% to that figure that I gave earlier. We also know that at least 1 to 2% of the population have personalities for letters, numbers, days of the week, months of the year, so we would have to add that on as well. But it does really come down to what you think synesthesia is. If you think these numbers are getting quite high, they are, but you might
是否有联觉。由此，我们相当清楚联觉在人口中的比例至少为4.4%。所以至少每23个人中就有一个人有联觉。在那项研究中，我们观察了大约140种不同类型的联觉，但我们错过了一些非常关键的类型。所以我们也独立地知道，大约10%的人看到时间、数字或字母在空间中排列。现在，这会给刚才给出的数字再增加10%左右。我们还知道，至少1%到2%的人口对字母、数字、星期几、月份有性格特征，所以我们也必须加上这一点。但这确实归结为你认为什么是联觉。如果你认为这些数字变得相当高，它们确实很高，但你可能
want to question whether numbers mapped out in space, whether time mapped out in space, is a synesthesia, because 10% of the population experiencing that makes us start to question, well, is this really synesthesia at all? But a very simple answer is at least 4% of the population. Now, that's an interesting prevalence because that feels small. 4.4% feels small, but it's actually equivalent to the entire population of the United States in the world. So if you were to gather all synesthetes together, that would be 307 million synesthetes worldwide, which is, you know, somewhere approximating the USA population. So it's a rare condition, but not insignificant.
想要质疑在空间中排列的数字、在空间中排列的时间是否是联觉，因为10%的人口体验到这一点让我们开始质疑，嗯，这真的是联觉吗？但一个非常简单的答案是至少4%的人口。现在，这是一个有趣的患病率，因为它感觉很小。4.4%感觉很小，但它实际上相当于美国在世界上的总人口。所以如果你把所有的联觉者聚集在一起，全世界将有3.07亿联觉者，这大约接近美国的人口。所以这是一种罕见的疾病，但并非微不足道。
And do you know, is it more common in men or women, or is it equally distributed? See, that's a very nice question again because it speaks to methodologies. So this early study of prevalence conducted by placing an advert in the newspaper and asking synesthetes to come forward gave the very, very strong impression that it was a female trait because I think something like eight times as many female synesthetes were found as males. So it put across the message that synesthesia was a female trait and that stayed with us for about decade. However, it turns out that that was a trick of the methodology, a confound in the methodology, because in fact, we know from many other studies that women with unusual conditions are simply
你知道，它是男性多还是女性多，还是分布均匀？看，这又是一个非常好的问题，因为它涉及方法论。所以这项通过在报纸上刊登广告并要求联觉者站出来进行的早期患病率研究，给人的印象非常强烈，认为这是一种女性特质，因为我认为发现的女性联觉者人数是男性的八倍左右。所以它传达了一个信息，即联觉是一种女性特质，这伴随了我们大约十年。然而，事实证明，那是方法论上的一个诡计，方法论中的一个混杂因素，因为事实上，我们从许多其他研究中知道，患有异常疾病的女性只是
more likely to come forward. So what we actually have is a condition which is balanced across the senses. When you go out and screen people through a large population, you find the same number is the same number of male and female synesthetes. But when you ask them to come forward, the men hold back and the women reach out to scientists. I mentioned in the introduction that in the past couple of decades, scientists have begun using brain scans to understand what's happening in the brains of people with synesthesia. What have they found? Do the brains of people with synesthesia look different or function differently from the brains
更有可能站出来。所以我们实际上拥有的是一种在感官上平衡的疾病。当你走进人群并通过大量人口进行筛查时，你会发现男性和女性联觉者的数量是相同的。但当你要求他们站出来时，男性会退缩，而女性会向科学家伸出援手。我在介绍中提到，在过去的几十年里，科学家们已经开始使用脑部扫描来了解联觉者大脑中发生了什么。他们发现了什么？联觉者的大脑看起来不同，或者功能与没有联觉的人的大脑不同吗？
of people who don't have it? Yeah, I think brain imaging in synesthesia has been the most important scientific step forward in 200 years. I remember giving synesthesia lectures and synesthesia talks before the advent of these brain imaging findings. And I would spend the entire talk trying to persuade people that synesthesia was real. Now, somewhere around 2005, we got a sudden proliferation of imaging studies. And that was wonderful because now when I give synesthesia talks, the first thing I do is show the brain of a synestate in an fMRI image, for example, and the brain of a control, and they're so very different that I no longer have to struggle to persuade people on genuineness. So what do they show? These brain imaging studies show very nicely that the brains of synesthetes are different to those of people without synesthesia. They're different in their functionality. So in fMRI, we can see that. Color selective regions or regions close to colour areas in the visual cortex will light up in response to reading black and white numbers for synesthetes,
是的，我认为联觉中的脑成像在200年来是最重要的科学进步。我记得在这些脑成像发现出现之前，我做过联觉讲座和联觉演讲。我会花整个演讲的时间试图说服人们联觉是真实的。现在，大约在2005年左右，我们突然出现了大量的成像研究。这太棒了，因为现在当我做联觉演讲时，我做的第一件事就是展示一个联觉者的大脑在fMRI图像中，例如，以及一个对照组的大脑，它们是如此不同，以至于我不再需要努力去说服人们它的真实性。那么它们显示了什么？这些脑成像研究很好地显示，联觉者的大脑与没有联觉的人的大脑不同。它们在功能上是不同的。所以在fMRI中，我们可以看到这一点。颜色选择性区域或视觉皮层中靠近颜色区域的区域会在联觉者阅读黑白数字时亮起，
when obviously for controls those same regions would only light up if they were exposed to colour in the real world. And also some very nice data from our Dutch colleagues has shown that synesthetes have different structural qualities in their brain. so differences in their white matter coherence in different parts of the brain. So greater white matter connectivity, near color selective regions, for example. Also, other interesting differences, differences in frontal areas, differences in parietal areas that might be linked to a greater binding. So binding is where we bring together different features of the world. So, for example, if I look at a green or apple, the greenness,
而对于对照组来说，同样的区域显然只有在现实世界中接触到颜色时才会亮起。而且我们荷兰同事的一些非常好的数据也表明，联觉者的大脑具有不同的结构质量。所以大脑不同部位的白质相干性存在差异。例如，颜色选择性区域附近的白质连接性更高。此外，还有其他有趣的差异，额叶区域的差异，顶叶区域的差异，这可能与更强的绑定有关。所以绑定是我们把世界的不同特征聚集在一起的地方。例如，如果我看着一个绿色的苹果，绿色，
is in one part of my brain, the shape of the apple is in another part of my brain, the binding region helps to bring those pieces of information together, and synestites have differences in parietal areas that deal with binding, almost as if they're overbinding features. They're not only binding the colours of apples to the shapes of apples, they're binding the colours of apples to letters and numbers and music and so on. So yeah, brain imaging is really revolutionised what you do. So do researchers like you have any theories as to why synesthesia develops? And is it hereditary? Do you, is there a cause? Or you're just born with it? So when the question of inheritance, it does seem to be genetically endowed in some way, rather than, well, for a start, we do know,
在我大脑的一个部分，苹果的形状在另一个部分，绑定区域有助于把这些信息片段聚集在一起，而联觉者在处理绑定的顶叶区域有差异，几乎就像他们过度绑定了特征。他们不仅把苹果的颜色绑定到苹果的形状上，他们还把苹果的颜色绑定到字母、数字、音乐等等上。所以是的，脑成像确实彻底改变了你的工作。那么像你这样的研究人员是否有关于联觉为什么会发展的理论？它是遗传的吗？你，有原因吗？还是你天生就有？所以当谈到遗传问题时，它似乎在某种程度上是基因赋予的，而不是，嗯，首先，我们确实知道，
first of all, that it passes down through families. So a study back in 2005 with my colleague Jamie Ward showed that if you have synesthesia in the family, you're much more likely to have it sort of, you're more likely to have it popping up through generations than much more likely than you expect from chance alone. So it's passing through families. Now, of course, it could be learned. It could be parents teaching children. But we know that's not the case for several reasons. First of all, parents and children are likely to have very different kinds of synesthesia. So what's being passed on is a sort of predisposition for synesthesia. But you might have a parent with coloured letters whose son has tasty words.
首先，它在家族中遗传。所以2005年我和我的同事杰米·沃德进行的一项研究表明，如果你的家族中有联觉，你更有可能在几代人中出现这种情况，比你仅凭偶然预期的可能性要大得多。所以它在家族中遗传。当然，它可能是后天习得的。可能是父母教给孩子。但我们知道事实并非如此，原因有几个。首先，父母和孩子可能患有非常不同类型的联觉。所以遗传的是一种联觉的易感性。但你可能有一个患有彩色字母的父母，而他的儿子有美味的词语。
And so that suggests it's not being taught through the generations. And quite often for that reason, families are not aware that they have so much synesthesia going on. So if I'm a person with coloured letters, why would I suddenly ask my child, what's the taste of Tuesday? It wouldn't happen. So quite often you get these families with multiple variants appearing. And then there are more direct genetics finding. So I mentioned earlier Julian Asher did some pioneering research with Simon Baron Co. going to go in on the genetics. More recently, the Max Planck Institute in Nymegan has got a fantastic
所以这表明它不是通过几代人传授的。而且通常因为这个原因，家庭并没有意识到他们有这么多的联觉发生。所以如果我是一个有彩色字母的人，我为什么要突然问我的孩子，星期二是什么味道？这不会发生。所以通常你会发现这些家庭出现了多种变体。然后还有更直接的遗传学发现。所以我之前提到朱利安·阿舍与西蒙·巴伦-科恩在遗传学方面进行了一些开创性的研究。最近，奈梅亨的马克斯·普朗克研究所进行了一个非常棒的
genetics project going on, screening hundreds and hundreds and hundreds, hopefully thousands and thousands of synesthetes and finding hotspots on chromosomes that are suggestive of synesthesia. It's unfortunately, it's not a clean picture. Sometimes in the genetics, it's quite easy to point to genes. What we're finding is that different families seem to have different families and different variants of synesthesia seem to have different genetic profiles. So it hasn't been a very easy task or a very clean picture, but we have got these areas on the genome that are hot spots, if you like, for certain kinds of synesthesia in certain families. If a person with synesthesia experiences trauma, such as a blow to the head or even a very high fever, is that something that could make the synesthesia disappear? And conversely, if you didn't have it, but then you experienced a blow to the head, could it triggers
遗传学项目，筛选了成百上千，希望是成千上万的联觉者，并发现了染色体上暗示联觉的热点。不幸的是，这不是一个清晰的图景。有时在遗传学中，很容易指出基因。我们发现的是，不同的家庭似乎有不同的家庭，不同的联觉变体似乎有不同的遗传特征。所以这不是一个非常容易的任务或一个非常清晰的图景，但我们确实在基因组上有了这些热点区域，如果你愿意的话，是某些家庭中某些联觉的热点。如果一个联觉者经历了创伤，比如头部受到重击，甚至是非常高的高烧，那是可能导致联觉消失的事情吗？反过来，如果你没有它，但后来你经历了头部重击，它能触发
synesthesia? Or is that just an off-the-wall question? Actually, I think both those things are true. There are rare cases of acquired synesthesia after trauma. There are also cases of synesthesia disappearing under certain circumstances. Now, it's not very well studied because obviously we can't replicate this very one in the lab and nor would we want to because I wouldn't be the person to take away a synesthesia. But there are cases and there's anecdotal reports. There's some really reliable anecdotal reports. So there is a case of a very prominent synestead who very sadly experienced the Japanese earthquake and felt for some time afterwards that his synesthesia was deadened.
联觉吗？还是那只是一个离谱的问题？实际上，我认为这两件事都是真的。创伤后获得性联觉的罕见案例是存在的。在某些情况下，联觉消失的案例也是存在的。现在，它没有得到很好的研究，因为显然我们不能在实验室里复制这个，我们也不想这样做，因为我不会是那个夺走联觉的人。但确实有案例，也有轶事报告。有一些非常可靠的轶事报告。所以有一个非常著名的联觉者的案例，他非常悲伤地经历了日本地震，并在之后的一段时间里感到他的联觉消失了。
And that was quite a troubling thing for him to deal with. Luckily, it's come back. I've had also synesthetes contacting me, asking me about medication. They're on a medication, and suddenly the synesthesia is attenuated. When we give large surveys to synesthetes and ask them for self-reports, sometimes reports of caffeine making differences. But it's very hard for us to pin this down in the lab. So quite often you'll find these reports in case study,
这对处理来说是一件非常令人不安的事情。幸运的是，它又回来了。我也曾有联觉者联系我，询问我关于药物的问题。他们正在服用某种药物，突然联觉减弱了。当我们对联觉者进行大规模调查并要求他们进行自我报告时，有时会有关于咖啡因产生差异的报告。但我们在实验室里很难确定这一点。所以通常你会发现这些报告在案例研究中，
which are really useful. So one thing that you've written about that I found surprising was that people are not always reliable reporters of whether they have synesthesia. Some people with it don't realize they have it. Some non-cinesthetes will say that they do. Why is that? And how do you test to determine whether someone actually has synesthesia? So the first time I came across it, I was really surprised by quite how, in our
这真的很有用。所以你写过的一件让我感到惊讶的事情是，人们并不总是关于他们是否有联觉的可靠报告者。一些患有联觉的人并没有意识到他们有。一些非联觉者会说他们有。为什么会这样？你如何测试以确定某人是否真的有联觉？所以第一次遇到这种情况时，我真的很惊讶，在我们的
accurate self-report is in synesthesia. Let me answer this by telling you how we verify synesthesia first of all. So we have a very nice test for synesthesia that seems robust and has been used since 1989, early 90s. Again, this was a very nice test that Simon Baron Cohen was able to pioneer. So we test synesthetes by looking for a trait called consistency over time. So what we do is we ask synesthetes to tell us their associations. And in fact, we do this in more sophisticated ways.
联觉中的自我报告是准确的。让我先回答你我们如何验证联觉。所以我们有一个非常好的联觉测试，看起来很稳健，并且自1989年、90年代初以来一直被使用。同样，这是一个西蒙·巴伦-科恩能够开创的非常好的测试。所以我们通过寻找一种称为“随时间的一致性”的特质来测试联觉者。所以我们做的是要求联觉者告诉我们他们的联想。事实上，我们以更复杂的方式做到这一点。
So, for example, we have tests that show the letters and numbers in a random order. Every time a grapheme appears, the synestite's required to choose the specific synesthetic colour from a really fine-grained colour palette that has like 16 million colours. So an A will appear, the synestate will choose their exact shade of red. A seven will appear, the synestep will choose their exact shade of red. of green and so on. And once they get to the end of the test, we surprise synesthetes and we repeat it. So they do the whole thing over and over again. And they can do this anything from twice to maybe three times. And what we're able, what we have at the end is each letter and number with
例如，我们有测试显示字母和数字是随机顺序的。每当一个字素出现时，联觉者需要从一个非常细致的颜色调色板中选择特定的联觉颜色，该调色板有大约1600万种颜色。所以一个A会出现，联觉者会选择他们确切的红色阴影。一个7会出现，联觉者会选择他们确切的红色阴影。绿色等等。一旦他们完成了测试，我们就会给联觉者一个惊喜，我们重复它。所以他们一遍又一遍地做整个事情。他们可以做任何事情，从两次到也许三次。我们最终拥有的是每个字母和数字，带有
the colours given to it over time by the same synesthet. And then we can use a technique that allows us to look at colour distances. So when I ask you for the colour of A, the first time, and the second time, I plot those colours in space and I say, how close are they in space? Now, if you are consistent, those colours will be very close in colour space. You'll have said the same shade of red twice. If you ask a control, they'll be inventing it, making it up very inconsistent, very large distances in colour space. So we can quantify the consistency of a synestite in terms of distances in colour space.
同一个联觉者随时间给出的颜色。然后我们可以使用一种技术，允许我们观察颜色距离。所以当我问你A的颜色时，第一次和第二次，我在空间中绘制这些颜色，我说，它们在空间中有多近？现在，如果你是一致的，这些颜色在颜色空间中会非常接近。你会两次说出相同的红色阴影。如果你问一个对照组，他们会发明它，编造它，非常不一致，在颜色空间中距离非常大。所以我们可以根据颜色空间中的距离来量化联觉者的一致性。
and this shows us that synesthetes are very, very, very consistent. You're not going to fool them. If you say what colour is seven, they're always going to tell you exactly the same shade of, I don't know, subtle, lime, green. They're going to be spot on. And controls are going to be inconsistent. And so we have a threshold of consistency. Synesthetes have to be above the threshold in order to be validated as a synestead.
这向我们表明，联觉者非常、非常、非常一致。你不会愚弄他们。如果你说7是什么颜色，他们总是会告诉你完全相同的，我不知道，微妙的、酸橙绿的阴影。他们会非常准确。而对照组会不一致。所以我们有一个一致性阈值。联觉者必须高于该阈值才能被验证为联觉者。
So when we run these tests, we usually start by saying, first of all, this is synesthesia. Have you got synesthesia? And you would think that everybody who says yes, goes on to be consistent and everybody who says no goes on to be inconsistent. But actually what we find is that for every true consistent synestete who says they have synesthesia, there are five non-cinestites saying they have synesthesia. And the reasons are actually not too surprising. There's a tiny bit of social desirability. It's quite nice to say you have something interesting.
所以当我们进行这些测试时，我们通常首先说，首先，这是联觉。你有联觉吗？你会认为每个说“是”的人都会保持一致，而每个说“否”的人都会不一致。但实际上我们发现，对于每个说他们有联觉的真正一致的联觉者，有五个非联觉者说他们有联觉。原因实际上并不太令人惊讶。有一点点社会期望。说你有一些有趣的东西是很好的。
but actually there are a lot of artists who say they have synesthesia because what they have is a really fine-grained appreciation for colour and that's quite easy to confuse. So lots of the non-cinestites reporting synesthesia are artists, some of them are just sort of, some of them are just mistaken, some of them are just not concentrating. But all in all, if I ever now review papers on synesthesia where there's no consistency test, it's dead in the water because you don't know you have synesthetes. So you were talking about artists and creative types. Is it more likely that a person who is creative and is an artist would have synesthesia?
但实际上有很多艺术家说他们有联觉，因为他们拥有的是对颜色非常细致的鉴赏力，这很容易混淆。所以很多报告有联觉的非联觉者是艺术家，他们中的一些人只是，他们中的一些人只是弄错了，他们中的一些人只是没有集中注意力。但总而言之，如果我现在审查没有一致性测试的联觉论文，它就死定了，因为你不知道你是否有联觉者。所以你在谈论艺术家和创意类型。一个有创造力的人和艺术家更有可能有联觉吗？
Is there actually some association? Sure, yes, there seems to be. So first of all, if you look within creative disciplines, you're more likely to find synesthetes. Now, that makes it difficult because artists are more likely to inaccurately say they have synesthesia, but there's still more synesthesia among artistic people. So you have to really use these careful tests. But yes, you find synestit's more likely to go into artistic professions and those professions are tied to their synesthesia.
实际上有什么关联吗？当然，是的，似乎有。所以首先，如果你在创意学科中观察，你更有可能找到联觉者。现在，这使得它很困难，因为艺术家更有可能不准确地说他们有联觉，但艺术人群中仍然有更多的联觉。所以你必须真正使用这些仔细的测试。但是的，你发现联觉者更有可能进入艺术职业，而这些职业与他们的联觉有关。
So more musicians with coloured music synesthesia, for example. We can also find evidence of higher creativity with lab tests. So for example, a test of creativity that's quite well-known. known is the remote associates test. And in that test, you're given three words such as, you're given three words and you have to provide the fourth word that links them all. And I have to think carefully about this so I don't reveal the linking word, but an example might be boot, this is tough, boot, ground, summer. Now, those three words are linked by one other word and that other word is camp. So boot camp, summer camp, campground. And this is a test of
例如，更多的音乐家有彩色音乐联觉。我们还可以通过实验室测试找到更高创造力的证据。例如，一个相当著名的创造力测试是远程联想测试。在该测试中，你被给出三个词，例如，你被给出三个词，你必须提供将它们全部联系起来的第四个词。我必须仔细考虑这一点，以免我透露连接词，但一个例子可能是靴子，这很难，靴子，地面，夏天。现在，这三个词由另一个词连接，那个词是营地。所以训练营，夏令营，露营地。这是一个测试
creativity and synesthetes performed very well in this test. We also have evidence that this creativity is starting quite early. So we have recently finished a large ERC funded project. So European Research Council funded us to look at synesthesia in children for five years. And we can even see those creativity traits emerging early in children. So when we find children with synesthesia from the general population, so we're not relying on people to come forward. We've screened thousands of children. We've found the synesthetes among them. And we look at their personality. And the children don't really realize they're special. The parents don't know that their children have synesthesia. But everybody concurs that these synesthetes are higher in the trait of openness to experiences,
创造力，联觉者在这个测试中表现非常好。我们还有证据表明这种创造力开始得很早。所以我们最近完成了一个大型的ERC资助项目。所以欧洲研究理事会资助我们研究儿童联觉五年。我们甚至可以看到这些创造力特质在儿童早期就出现了。所以当我们从普通人群中找到患有联觉的儿童时，我们不依赖人们主动站出来。我们筛选了成千上万的儿童。我们在他们中间找到了联觉者。我们观察他们的性格。孩子们并没有真正意识到他们很特别。父母不知道他们的孩子有联觉。但每个人都同意这些联觉者在“对经验的开放性”这一特质上更高，
which is linked to intellectual curiosity but also creativity. So children themselves feel that they're more creative in their personalities, their parents feel they have more creative personalities. And we can see this from really a young age, from the age of around. I think the children we tested were between six and ten. And we can see these effects emerging, you know, by, if not by six, then by, you know, seven or eight. So, yes, creative population. So you've done research that's found that even though most people do not have synesthesia,
这与智力好奇心有关，但也与创造力有关。所以孩子们自己觉得他们的性格更有创造力，他们的父母觉得他们有更有创造力的性格。我们可以从很小的时候就看到这一点，从大约。我想我们测试的孩子在六到十岁之间。我们可以看到这些影响在，如果不是六岁，那么在七或八岁时出现。所以，是的，创意人群。所以你做过研究，发现即使大多数人没有联觉，
they do have cross-sensory experiences or associations, for example, associating higher-pitched tones with brighter colors. Can you tell us about that research and how it relates to synesthesia? Sure. This is always an area of research that can really play with my head, because we look at many different sensory domains and we look at how they cross over in many different ways. so I'm going to think carefully. So the one that you just described as actually a great finding by,
他们确实有跨感官体验或联想，例如，将高音调与更明亮的颜色联系起来。你能告诉我们关于那项研究以及它与联觉的关系吗？当然。这总是一个真正能让我头疼的研究领域，因为我们观察许多不同的感官领域，我们观察它们如何以许多不同的方式交叉。所以我将仔细思考。所以你刚才描述的那个实际上是一个伟大的发现，由，
among other people, my colleague, J.B. Ward, he has shown that people systematically associate the pitch of music with colours in several ways. So, for example, higher pitch. So imagine a test where I play you sounds and I ask you to choose colours and you feel like you're randomly picking because I play you a high pitch sound, a low pitch sound, a stringed instrument, a piano, and I just ask you to pick colours. And you kind of, you're willing to do this task, although you suspend disbelief because you think you're going to be random. And actually, people are very, very consistent. Higher pitch sound maps to more luminant colours.
除其他人外，我的同事J.B.沃德，他已经证明人们系统地将音乐的音高与颜色以几种方式联系起来。例如，高音调。所以想象一个测试，我给你播放声音，我让你选择颜色，你觉得你是在随机选择，因为我给你播放高音调声音、低音调声音、弦乐器、钢琴，我只是让你选择颜色。你有点，你愿意做这个任务，尽管你暂停了怀疑，因为你认为你会是随机的。实际上，人们非常、非常一致。高音调声音映射到更明亮的颜色。
So imagine a piano, imagine I'm on a piano, and I'm tinkling on the high notes and I'm crashing on the low notes. And I say to you, which one of those is pale yellow? And you are much more likely to say that the pale yellow is the higher pitch note. Okay, and maybe deep dark purple is the low pitch note. So there's that, there's that association. But there are many, many, many of these associations. So we have shown that if you give people an identical sweetie, an identical candy, and it either has a rough surface or a smooth surface, they will think that the candy is more sour with the rough surface, even though it has the identical ingredients. And here's something quite fun.
所以想象一架钢琴，想象我在钢琴上，我在高音上叮当响，我在低音上猛击。我对你说，其中哪一个是浅黄色？你更有可能说浅黄色是高音调的音符。好的，也许深紫色是低音调的音符。所以有那种，有那种联想。但这些联想非常、非常、非常多。所以我们已经证明，如果你给人们一个相同的甜食，相同的糖果，它要么有一个粗糙的表面，要么有一个光滑的表面，他们会认为粗糙表面的糖果更酸，即使它有相同的成分。这里有一些非常有趣的事情。
We have recently been looking at the same phenomenon in dogs. So research in collaboration with my colleague David Reby and our student Anna Koshinovska, who's leading this research. We have taken domestic dogs into the lab and we show them different objects. So they're either objects of a different size or they're. elevated differently in space and we play sounds and we train the dogs in advance to go to the object that's making a sound and what we find is that they're much more likely to target the small object when the sound is high-pitched and the large object when the sound is low-pitched and similarly
我们最近一直在观察狗身上的相同现象。所以与我的同事大卫·雷比（David Reby）和我们的学生安娜·科什诺夫斯卡（Anna Koshinovska）合作的研究，她正在领导这项研究。我们把家犬带进实验室，我们给它们看不同的物体。所以它们要么是不同大小的物体，要么是。在空间中提升不同，我们播放声音，我们提前训练狗去寻找发出声音的物体，我们发现它们更有可能在声音高音调时瞄准小物体，在声音低音调时瞄准大物体，同样
when the sound is high-pitched they look up to an object up in space and when the sound is low-pitch, they look down to an object on the ground. So this shows associations between on the one-hand sound and on the other hand, the visual property of size or the visual property of elevation in space. And that's some really exciting work that's been really fun to conduct. Wow, that's amazing. So let me change gears a little bit because in addition to synesthesia, you study a variety of other brain and sensory differences. For example, as I said earlier, which is an extreme aversion to specific sounds, and Afantasia, which is the inability to picture things in your mind's eye. These seem like really disparate concepts, but how do they tie together?
当声音高音调时，它们向上看空间中的物体，当声音低音调时，它们向下看地面上的物体。所以这显示了声音与大小的视觉属性或空间中高度的视觉属性之间的联想。这是一些非常令人兴奋的工作，进行起来非常有趣。哇，那太神奇了。所以让我换个话题，因为除了联觉，你还研究各种其他大脑和感官差异。例如，正如我之前所说，这是对特定声音的极端厌恶，以及心盲症，即无法在脑海中想象事物的能力。这些看起来像是非常不同的概念，但它们是如何联系在一起的？
That's such a good question because... Or do they? Yeah, that's a really good question because I found myself working in synesthesia for a couple of decades and then being introduced to other sensory differences, finding them fascinating, berating myself for not having focus for effectively coming away from synesthesia, and then finding out over time that these different conditions are tied by kind of invisible thread. So all of them are sensory differences and they all share certain traits in common. For example, in terms of well-being, so we find that people with these sensory differences
这是一个很好的问题，因为……或者它们有联系吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题，因为我发现自己在联觉领域工作了几十年，然后被介绍给其他感官差异，发现它们很迷人，责备自己没有专注于有效地离开联觉，然后随着时间的推移发现这些不同的疾病被某种无形的线联系在一起。所以它们都是感官差异，它们都有某些共同的特质。例如，在幸福感方面，所以我们发现患有这些感官差异的人
even synesthesia that sometimes considered a gift can have impairments in their well-being, can have problems in their well-being. So, for example, in synesthesia, we found that people with synesthesia with verified synesthesia are significantly more likely to experience anxiety disorder than other people. We were really surprised about this. We weren't looking at particularly troubling variants. We were looking at coloured letters and numbers, higher rates of anxiety disorder. We've just finished a similar study in child synesthetes, and 30% of our child synesthetes under 10 qualify for sort of the category of anxiety disorder, which is really high, usually in children in our controls, we've found it at around less than 10, synesthetes at 30%. Wow. And similarly
即使是联觉，有时被认为是一种天赋，也会在他们的幸福感方面有损害，在他们的幸福感方面有问题。例如，在联觉中，我们发现患有联觉的、经过验证的联觉者比其他人更有可能经历焦虑症。我们对此感到非常惊讶。我们并没有观察特别令人困扰的变体。我们观察的是彩色字母和数字，焦虑症的发病率更高。我们刚刚在儿童联觉者中完成了一项类似的研究，我们10岁以下的儿童联觉者中有30%符合焦虑症的类别，这真的很高，通常在我们对照组的儿童中，我们发现它在10%左右，联觉者在30%。哇。同样
in these other disciplines, similarly in these other sensory differences. So misophonia itself is almost defined by difficulties in well-being. So misophonia can give rise to great anxiety. As well as, so misophonia is an extreme hatred of certain sounds. And those sounds tend to be bodily sounds like coughing or chewing or crunching or swallowing. And it can really give rise to these incredible differences in well-being, anxiety, rage, uncontrollable feelings, really, that we know are also linked to brain structure. And what we found in children as young as 10 is that children that we've been able to recognize as having misophonia are showing serious differences in their well-being, again, elevated anxiety, as you might expect, but also poorer quality of life, poorer satisfaction in life.
在这些其他学科中，在这些其他感官差异中也是如此。所以恐音症本身几乎是由幸福感的困难定义的。所以恐音症可以引起巨大的焦虑。以及，所以恐音症是对某些声音的极端仇恨。这些声音往往是身体声音，如咳嗽、咀嚼、咀嚼或吞咽。它真的可以引起这些令人难以置信的幸福感差异，焦虑，愤怒，无法控制的感觉，真的，我们知道这也与大脑结构有关。我们发现10岁的儿童中，我们能够识别为患有恐音症的儿童在他们的幸福感方面表现出严重的差异，同样，正如你可能预期的那样，焦虑升高，而且生活质量较差，生活满意度较低。
And then there's also the link with autistic-like traits. So the more we look at these sensory differences, the more we see parallels with and unlawful. overlaps with autism. Now, it's not the case that having synesthesia means you're autistic, but it does mean that you're elevated on tests of autism in certain areas. So in misophonia, for example, you're significantly more likely to be diagnosed or recognized as having autism than the average person. In synesthesia, you're elevated on the traits of attention to detail. in synesthesia, you're elevated on the autistic trait of attention to detail. And in misophonia, no, and in Afantasia, you're elevated in the autistic traits of social
此外，还有与自闭症特征的联系。我们对这些感官差异研究得越多，就越能发现它们与自闭症之间的相似之处和重叠之处。当然，并不是说有联觉就意味着你是自闭症患者，但这确实意味着你在某些自闭症测试中的得分会更高。例如，在恐音症患者中，被诊断或认定为患有自闭症的可能性明显高于普通人。在联觉中，你在“注重细节”这一自闭症特征上的得分会更高。而在恐音症中，不，在心盲症中，你在“社交困难”和“想象力”这些自闭症特征上的得分会更高。
difficulties and imagination. And so, yes, there's this overlap of autistic traits, there's this overlapping well-being, poorer well-being. So the more I look at many different sensory conditions, the more I'm convinced that they all really fit together in a kind of coherent whole. Here's one I'll throw at you. So we had a guest a few months back, did an episode on face blindness. And one of the people is someone I know who has been diagnosed with face blindness.
所以，是的，存在这种自闭症特征的重叠，也存在这种幸福感较差的重叠。因此，我研究的感官状况越多，就越确信它们实际上都以一种连贯的整体结合在一起。我给你举个例子。几个月前我们有一位嘉宾，做了一期关于面孔失认症的节目。其中一个人是我认识的，他被诊断出患有面孔失认症。
And she recently also learned that she has Afantasia. Have you looked at those connections? We have. We have and we are actually. So I think in self-report, people with Afentasia report being poorer at face. on average. And a very nice study we're conducting here at Sussex, led by my PhD student Carla Dance, and in collaboration with my colleague Graham Hull, who's a witness recognition, a face recognition expert, we've been able to give identicates to people with Afantasia. And we
她最近也了解到自己患有心盲症。你们研究过这些联系吗？我们研究过。我们确实研究过，而且实际上……我认为在自我报告中，心盲症患者平均而言报告说他们的面孔识别能力较差。在萨塞克斯大学，由我的博士生卡拉·丹斯领导，并与我的同事、面孔识别专家格雷厄姆·赫尔合作，我们正在进行一项非常好的研究，我们已经能够为心盲症患者提供面部合成工具。
show them a face, and then we ask them to reconstruct the face using these identicates, and then we give the reconstructed face to a group of controls. and ask them how similar is this reconstructed face with the original? And we do that once for our people with Afantasia and once for controls. And we're in the middle of doing that study right now. And we can see trends in the direction that we'd expect, but we need to finish that study to find out exactly whether it's significant. But it does look at the moment as if it's trending in the direction of what we would expect,
我们向他们展示一张脸，然后要求他们使用这些工具重建这张脸，然后我们将重建的脸交给一组对照组，并询问他们这张重建的脸与原始脸有多相似。我们为心盲症患者做一次，为对照组做一次。我们现在正在进行这项研究。我们可以看到我们预期的趋势，但我们需要完成这项研究，才能确切地知道它是否具有统计学意义。但目前看来，它确实朝着我们预期的方向发展，
which is poorer face recall for people with Afantasia. although I need to add something. This is only a typical of the average Afantasic. So what we actually find is a real spread and it's quite interesting because I have Afantasia myself but I'm almost a super recogniser.
也就是心盲症患者的面孔回忆能力较差。尽管我需要补充一点。这只是心盲症患者的平均水平。我们实际上发现存在很大的差异，这很有趣，因为我自己也有心盲症，但我几乎是一个“超级识别者”。
So when I perform tests of face recognition I'm almost good enough to work for the police. How am I doing that? How am I doing that? I have no mental imagery but I just know very, I'm just able to pick out a face in the crowd very well. So there you go.
所以当我在进行面孔识别测试时，我的表现好到几乎可以为警察工作。我是怎么做到的？我是怎么做到的？我没有心理意象，但我只是非常擅长在人群中认出一张脸。所以就是这样。
It's a spread. But the average person is less good than controls. So I'm just wondering if particularly misophonia and Afantasia are debilitating to the people who have these syndromes and is it possible to help someone learn to diminish, say, an aversion to sounds or to teach people how to see things in their mind's eye? Yeah, definitely. And I think that is definitely happening a lot more for misophonia. So misophonia is defined as an almost chronic condition.
这是一种差异。但普通人的表现不如对照组。我只是想知道，特别是恐音症和心盲症是否对患有这些综合征的人造成了困扰？是否有可能帮助人们学会减少对声音的厌恶，或者教人们如何在脑海中看到事物？是的，绝对可以。我认为恐音症方面的情况确实正在发生很大变化。恐音症被定义为一种几乎是慢性的疾病。
And misophonia is also really a topic of focus for clinicians. A lot of clinicians are trying to find out exactly how we can fix this problem. There are some long-term clinical treatment options. Cognitive behavioral therapy has been tried. a tinnitus retraining therapy, a counter-conditioning therapy. They aim to reconceptualise the individual's relationship with sound, or they repair unpleasant sounds with more pleasant responses. Some approaches combine therapy with gentle exposure.
恐音症也是临床医生关注的重点。许多临床医生正试图找出我们究竟该如何解决这个问题。有一些长期的临床治疗选择。认知行为疗法已经尝试过，还有耳鸣再训练疗法、反条件作用疗法。它们旨在重新构建个人与声音的关系，或者用更愉悦的反应来修复不愉快的声音。一些方法将治疗与温和的暴露疗法相结合。
It's still quite a young science. It's still quite a young science. There isn't really an outstanding treatment that's emerging a bunch of. all others. We're just trying, clinicians are just trying different options at the moment, but some of them are effective, but not exclusive, not across the board. Aphantasia is an interesting one. People aren't really trying to improve imagery at the moment in Aphantasics. I mean, I know personally, I found out I had Aphantasia around 10 years ago. I was having an interesting chat with a colleague about synesthetes, and I said to him, these synesthetes are,
这仍然是一门相当年轻的科学。这仍然是一门相当年轻的科学。目前还没有出现一种能够脱颖而出的卓越疗法。临床医生目前只是在尝试不同的选择，其中一些是有效的，但并非普遍适用。心盲症是一个有趣的案例。目前人们并没有真正试图改善心盲症患者的意象能力。我的意思是，我个人大约在10年前发现自己患有心盲症。当时我正在和一位同事聊关于联觉者的话题，我对他说，这些联觉者，
reporting that they can see pictures in their mind's eyes. So if I say pig, they literally see an image of a pig. And I was speaking to my colleague Bob Blogie who said, well, that's what everybody does, isn't it? And I said, no, you don't understand. They see a picture in their mind. He said, yeah, that's what everybody does. So from that moment, 10 years ago, I have tried, personally speaking, I've tried to construct images. I don't, I haven't had a great deal of success, to be honest. Although that's an N of one, so who knows, so maybe we might try it. But really, The difference between Afantasia and Misophonia is that people with Afantasia are getting on fine. They're just getting on fine with their life.
报告说他们能在脑海中看到图片。所以如果我说“猪”，他们真的会看到一头猪的图像。我当时正在和我的同事鲍勃·布洛吉交谈，他说：“嗯，那是每个人都会做的事，不是吗？”我说：“不，你不明白。他们能在脑海中看到一张图片。”他说：“是的，那是每个人都会做的事。”所以从10年前的那一刻起，我个人尝试过构建图像。老实说，我并没有取得太大的成功。虽然这只是一个个案，所以谁知道呢，也许我们可以尝试一下。但实际上，心盲症和恐音症的区别在于，心盲症患者的生活过得很好。他们只是过着自己的生活。
They really have no idea. They're different. They understand visual imagery as a metaphor. You know, they, it's really not a big deal in my life. I'm not very good at interior decorating. I find that quite hard. What's this sofa going to look like against that wall? Really, apart from that, it's fine.
他们真的不知道自己与众不同。他们将视觉意象理解为一种隐喻。你知道，这在我的生活中真的不是什么大不了的事。我不擅长室内装饰。我觉得那很难。那张沙发靠在那面墙上会是什么样子？真的，除了那个，其他都很好。
Well, this has been just amazingly interesting, Dr. Simna. I've really enjoyed talking to you. I appreciate your taking the time. Thank you. Thanks so much. It's been a pleasure. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.
好吧，西姆纳博士，这真是太有趣了。我真的很喜欢和你交谈。感谢你抽出时间。谢谢。非常感谢。这是一种荣幸。谢谢。你可以在 www. 找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。
www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
www.speakingofpsychology.org 或者在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。